if you follow the news about ukraine at
all you'll know that since the war
started canadians have gathered and
shipped a river of supplies to the
battlefields and to ukraine's
overwhelmed institutions what's
happening today is we're
figuring out exactly what needs to go
directly
by shipping container in a donated space
on an abbotsford farm saturday we caught
up with john lowe a military veteran of
afghanistan he's now a walking example
of canada's aid movement for ukraine
he's personally delivered suitcases full
of expensive items to the country
now he's quarterbacking the loading of
this 40-foot container set to ship out
monday one of the things i realize
really quickly is their equipment is
is incredibly outdated well ottawa has
supplied some weapons canada is just not
in a position to send something like
javelin missiles
so more and more it's looking like our
legacy will be things like this
striker hospital beds advanced first aid
kits even an ultrasound machine some of
it bought much of it donated
since the war started this is going to
be my third and fourth container for
years before the russian invasion
retired businessman roman sawicki had
been shipping supplies to ukraine so he
had a network of contacts in place to
move things swiftly which is another
part of canada's aid story much of it is
people to people
self-organizing online
sawicki says ordinary canadians are
making as meaningful a contribution as
any other country i can't think of
another country that could come close to
what ukraine with canada has been
sending zawiki says there are no fewer
than 50 hospitals in ukraine right now
working with canadian sourced supplies
this batch will go to halifax then
poland much of it will end up near the
ukrainian front lines
in abbotsford paul johnson global news